bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france comment vous
justifiez le troisième mandat d'alassane
ouattara que l'opposition juge
anticonstitutionnelle d'abord les
positionner très mal fondé de parler du
mandat requis constitutionnel
c'est le premier mandat de la troisième
république et ce qui est surprenant
c'est de constater que nos produits
aient qui n'a rien à proposer par son
temps a dit que ouattara n'est pas et
décide mais s'il n'est pas éligible il
est que la possibilité au juge
constitutionnel a décidé donc chacun
célèbre l'ancien président bédié laurent
gbagbo
le ft pour abu et but certaines
personnes disent que non ouattara n'est
pas éligible mais qu'il éclate le
conseil construction décidée
ils veulent déjà décidé avant le conseil
constitutionnel c'est un peu ça notre
problème en afrique c'est que les gens
ne savent pas quel est leur rôle
quelle est la fonction et surtout c'est
sur quoi ils doivent se prononcer
politiquement à l'intervention de
monsieur bédié démarrant gbagbo et
consorts ces décisions et des du moins
des déclarations qui n'ont pas
d'importance
cependant ce a eu des effets puisque tu
a galvanisé les quelques militants
quoiqu'il reste et qui ont posé les
dames 5
vous comprenez qu est ce qui pose
problème c'est le cas ce qui pose
problème c'est le cumul justement des
mandats ce troisième mandat
il ya effectivement un débat autour de
rien débat constitutionnel sur
l'interprétation effectivement de la
constitution qui a été réformé mais
c'est le cumul des mandats qui pose
problème pour l'opposition
vous savez il n'ya pas des départs
constitutionnel puisque là c'est les
juges consulaires qui va décider
maintenant quand vous parlez du cumul
des mandats c'est super surpris vous qui
est des journalistes qui travaillaient
dans niveau international on ne fallait
jamais de cumul de mandat de poutine
on n'est pas les germes et des cumuls de
mandat de paul biya vous ne parlez
jamais du cumul de mandat de certains
pays et mais c'est comme ça il s'agit de
la tri ou d'être là oui cumul de membres
un cumul des mandats non nous n'avons
noté mike on en parle le mieux de mandat
aussi bien ce qui concerne la russie
mais du cameroun aussi s'agissant des
manifestations qui sont interdites
jusqu'au 15 septembre
c'est une décision qui a été prise en
conseil des ministres avant
l'investiture du président alassane
ouattara aujourd'hui par son parti il ya
tout de même des violences qui se
poursuivent dans le pays en dehors
d'abidjan qui est complètement bouclée
est ce que est ce qu'il faut redouter
monsieur n'guessan une crise une
nouvelle crise post électorale
qu'est-ce qu'on est un peu plus de deux
mois de l'élection il n'y aura ni coupé
électoral ni post électorale il n'y en
aura pas ces quelques excités que
messieurs fétiche madame gbagbo et leurs
groupes ont poussé dans la rue tout en
faisant cueillir chez lui à la maison il
faut s violeur d'enfant ils amènent les
enfants des routes dont les parents
n'ont pas eu l'intelligence nécessaire
de leur ai dis ne faites pas ce suicide
peut aller dans la rue et vous verrez
que leurs revendications ce n'est pas
tellement le fait que ouattara soit
candidat ou pas mais c'est le fait
qu'ils avaient envie de casser des bus
et des maisons ici les suissesses le
gouvernement a décidé que il ne faille
pas autoriser de manifestation
ceci étant dit ceci étant dit sachez que
ce n'est pas la première fois que encore
dita von interdit des manifestations que
ce soit monsieur pouvez pré messieurs
bédié messieurs papou et tous les
régimes qui ont présidé il y a eu des
interdictions si tu ne fais pas la
différence cette fois-ci la différence
cette fois-ci c'est que le régime en
place le régime du président alassane
ouattara n'a pas tué sur la foule ils
n'ont pas demandé aux forces de défense
et de sécurité de tirer sur la foule
ça a été le cas à 95 comme bédié a fait
tirer dessus les les militants tu as été
le 4 autant de gbagbo où il ya eu près
de 5,5 et moi au moins je marque mais si
tu as un respirateur que quelques pas
non plus les manifestations interdites
les adultes ils ont leurs droits
constitutionnels par rapport à l'article
1 de la constitution
il peut marcher problème j'ai la
question de cinq questions ça concernait
la commission électorale qui a rejeté
les recours de l'ex président laurent
gbagbo de l'ancien chef rebelle
guillaume soro
de charles blé goudé qui contestaient
leur radiation des listes électorales
est ce que ça cette commission
électorale allait contester ce que ça
veut dire que l'élection elle est
verrouillée
je dis ce n'est pas une question
d'élection pays verrouillé
il faut qu'on sache une chose quand
quelqu'un est condamné 1 il n'a pas le
droit d'étudier tunis électoral ni des
électeurs
c'est aussi simple que ça notre loi
électorale est est claire non la
commission électorale indépendante n'a
fait qu'appliquer la loi
monsieur soro guillaume jusqu'à nouvel
avis a été condamné à 20 ans monsieur
papa jusqu'à nouvel avis dans les liens
de la détention au niveau de la cour
pénale internationale
alors comment voulez vous que des
personnes qui sont dans les liens de la
détention
je suis du racing électorale c'est
vraiment et c'est de la mauvaise foi qui
peut faire c'est le jour où de plus en
plus une liste électorale indûment ils
ne sont plus condamnés
c'est le jour où il n'y aura pas des
poursuites avec gisements déjà établi
que ces figures et signer ses lectures à
respecter quand même la loi électorale
mais je nous disons pas que parce que
monsieur gbagbo mais c est sur le cul
remous bien monsieur untel est
automatiquement
donc ils ont droit des figurines même
s'il a été condamné
merci à vous je merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup jouer rennes besson pour avoir
réagi en direct sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes membre du conseil
politique du rhdp le rassemblement des
houphouétistes pour la démocratie et la
paix